le nouvel accord états unis mexique
canada engendre des inquiétudes chez les
consommateurs qui s'interroge sur la
présence de produits laitiers américain
sur nos tablettes
l'accord n'est pas ratifiée ça peut
prendre encore deux ans avant que ce
soit fait présentement c'est statu quo
donc tous les blancs régulier vendus au
canada et du les canadiens quelle que
soit la marque
on ne peut offrir cette garantie pour
les boissons laitières
car elles peuvent être additionnées
d'ingrédients importer tous les produits
laitiers fabriqués à l'étranger et
importés doivent obligatoirement
indiquer le pays d'origine sur
l'emballage
quant aux les américains frére live qui
est récemment apparue sur les tablettes
sachez que cela n'a rien à voir avec le
nouvel accord économique
il s'agit d'un permis temporaire de 15
mois accordé à la compagnie coca cola en
attendant la construction d'une usine en
ontario fait relève devrait par la suite
utiliser le canadien enfin les logos des
producteurs laitiers du canada certifie
que les ingrédients laitiers sont 100 %
canadien
mais comme il s'agit d'une mesure
volontaire l'absence du logo ne signifie
pas pour autant que le led n'est pas
canadien n'ayant pas cru bon le faire
l'acte en ciel appris à ses dépends
dernièrement certains consommateurs
pensez à boire à faire à du lait
américain